et puis sachez à paris toujours qu'un
restaurant casher a été vandalisé dans
le 19e arrondissement cela s'est passé
dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi
l'établissement a suivi des dégradations
des tags à caractère antisémite ont été
inscrits comme vous le voyez sur ces
images les croix gammées et des
inscriptions faites à la peinture sur le
sol sur les tables les murs le
restaurant r et ensuite été saccagée
puis inondées voyez la réaction de la
maire de paris et du ministre de
l'intérieur français
je condamne avec la plus grande fermeté
cet odieux acte de vandalisme antisémite
contre un restaurant du 19e
arrondissement de paris
tout mon soutien à nos amis de la
communauté juive nous ne laisserons pas
passer ces images sont révoltantes ceux
qui crachent leur haine antisémite au
visage de nos compatriotes juifs me
trouveront toujours sur leur route
une enquête est en cours pour retrouver
les responsables de cette ignominie